But for real,
I'm having a good moment because I had to go drop my
something off for my daughter at school.
And because I've been very transparent
in a respectful way.
You know, there
you can always say
you got a high conflict
without dogging the other person,
but, you know,
you can explain, hey,
you could just point out
she like, hey,
I currently have 100% education,
making that. That.
That, uh. Right.
Was stripped of the other parents.
So you know what I mean?
You just kind of
help them see the situation for what it is without.
There's ways to do that.
But now when I go to the school,
they're so nice to me.
I go and I've talked to the receptionist
and I've explained the situation like this.
I don't get to see her talk to my kids.
She's like, how?
I had a father like that too.
I know what's going on.
And so now if I just have to drop off
the simplest thing,
I say, can you call her to the front
so I can say hi really quick?
No problems.
Doesn't even look, got it.
And I get to see my kids and say hi
and fucking skirt that,
you know what I mean?
Fuck them. They don't win.
They don't win.